let's brag on there all right a little
bit on air what's up dude it's good to
see you buddy back fresh fresh off the
Kansas City train how was KC KC Missouri
is a hey what did you get a whole new
jersey what I forgot about Kansas City
is that a lot of black people no yes
in fact great barbecue jazz jazz had one
of its Renaissance --iz its deriv they
have them incredible jazz clubs because
Kansas City was were a lot of the great
jazz musicians like develop their salads
I didn't realize that coffee great
restaurants crossroads hotel there's a
restaurant in there collage yeah I think
so the best food I've ever [ __ ] did
you say there I didn't stay there
Brandon I'm glad you asked so you
wouldn't visit the hotel I did why more
Stevie blue eyes Tex amigos dude look
where Brian puts us up yeah meanwhile
man [ __ ] five-star hotels or what
Stevie yeah you need to tell Brian to
spit the game well I made a mistake
because I don't know that's when Hilton
Kansas City Airport the Hilton Kansas
City Airport and I went soon as I read
here I know but remember I lost my
wallet we found it remember how I lost
my well weird we found it it was in my
garage
you just allowance you flock it and I've
had that happens right and that brewery
but I didn't have a driver's license on
my way it hurts and I went I can't run a
car here I have in KC you know I got an
uber around that's it that's probably
welcome to our 19 but yeah yeah who
still went to caller this guy this guy
cuz ubering from just mark you just use
putting the thing in scroll yeah but
yeah you do like Corinne connector I
like to explore meanwhile he's he cold I
was so bored in the Hilton
Kansas City where there's nothing around
you near the airport I cut my own hair I
YouTube how to cut my own hair you've
been doing that for but I was bored and
I really gave it the old I gave it the
old tremie trim oh well all right
and I know there are some deficits and
some problems get out gingka trinkets is
on here dude I had a photographer in
Milwaukee shot to Milwaukee and he took
pictures on well send me a picture man
sees everything that's how I look right
now you guys what do you mean I don't
know this guy here the Tyler Kenny is
yeah brother Taylor you in
Wow cool man text text my girl I'm
cutting my hair you know why I'd look
terrible I just I don't know
like I just don't want to look like this
in it yeah but then also is perfect
timing because Showtime was like oh
we're shooting this funny intro for the
special and they're like oh so you have
to have this same haircut how's it going
I'm growing my hair out like Bradley
Cooper them it well that doesn't work
here and also excuse me sir you're not
Bradley Cooper what are you talking he's
like he's like you hurt my feelings one
time a long time ago we were in [ __ ]
Austin and on a boat and an Aubree was
there and he was wakeboarding and he's
all muscular and out there there were
like a lot of girls around like every
time I felt self-conscious I was white
and sanity result Fanny has tattoos you
guys have had but you at least you're
big and handsome and tattooing and I'm
old and skinny and yeah and I thought to
myself when I go my god I'm looking at
Audrey and he had a shaved head how do I
go just like hat to myself almost I go I
gonna shave my head again and Brennan
goes he goes you don't shave your head
you're not gonna look like Aubrey you're
not gonna look like Aubrey sir you're
not gonna look at all I can you're gonna
look like a skinny guy with a shaved
head because you're gone bald and you're
old like he's super loud oh and then
those cops who stopped us on the
motorboat yeah it kind of recognized me
there's a little better about myself
like well there's no recognition
validation oh my god it was so funny how
dude how about yeah she'll come on
walkie different different now when I
sit out of the city
all right from there sorrowful and oh
cool there's a trump rally in the entire
city
it's yeah it's a it's all white
you like yeah it's America I was getting
looks cuz I'm tan year around
yeah but I have no idea we'll figure out
down the road there's some there's some
people have put that not missing any
meals and some people have put on some
weight I mean great town great crowds
yeah great well we'll be back won't eat
up the one place right we'll be back a
great great garage Eric Koston fan all
stand up from the Comedy Store black guy
yeah and then my opener black fellas on
Ahmad India Indian guy Santa modesty
probably so he's probably
Indian but Muslim because I'm out is a
correct Muslim and then we're talking
about it cuz I can a Muslim you got
black in a Muslim then you got a Mexican
basically yeah yeah so
I look Mexican yeah and then we're all
sitting down to eat in his dad's NASA
scientists rocket scientist Jesus Christ
smart guy I think that artists by the
way by the way asylum supposed to be a
doctor went Nam would do stand-up so his
family's not disappointed him so he says
they're not and I'm like I don't believe
a word you're saying but I go dude and I
would we're all in Pakistani nope okay
for a minute we're we're all a little
high and I go I got ask kind of Bank as
your dad bring in it's like who knows
about NASA yeah anyways I goes I don't
know the number was serious money gets
but he did you don't where to talk about
like he was especially Indian families
we don't talk about this right here's
what he's pulling it Bank like you'd
have to not really was the head engineer
at Lockheed Martin had engineer Oh head
engineer at Lockheed Martin's make no
he's a NASA rocket scientist
can you Google's [ __ ] isn't well he
went well I guarantee was probably
making more Lockheed Martin but I would
imagine NASA to get a guy of that
caliber the head injury remote head
engineer at Lockheed what the head
engineer I would imagine he'd have to
have way more money see that's not much
I thought so
yeah you make that in a month correct
sir it's a government job you're not
making much money Jesus the smartest
minds in the world you know hundred
grams right so [ __ ] up so at the end
of the day my guess is he he bribe made
a shitload of money and decided to go do
that for a while cuz he gets to work on
the most exciting pun physical scientist
with Sally ranging from 135 to underseas
for you know I thought they made more ya
know I can ask them poised on 60 grand
annual on average that's [ __ ] up you
know smart that do this also makes the
meanest ribs this side of the
Mississippi see what are you doing San
Jose you don't see a nose a improv at
all this year not yet no I don't know
well when you put on the books yeah he
they live up there in Silicon Valley
yeah rich you have up there okay his dad
makes these ribs he soaks them in like
Greek yogurt Jesus Christ
I'm telling you man hold on the best
thing that's ever touched my mouth I
believe that I've had ribs like that add
lamb ribs not like these did Tarek not
my mouth is watering
no self where they take they marinated
them in Greek yogurt yeah that's
it's weird cuz these guys Greek yeah it
was so good it was so good but I'll tell
what was in stirring well while the Sun
was we were eating pork ribs he's
telling about being Muslim at well but
you know those are pork ribs anyway I'm
not that muscle pretty funny yeah what
is it a cloven hoof you know if you're
Muslim or an Orthodox Jew you can't eat
a cloven hoof there's a medical reason
for that why disease [ __ ] they had day
they carry trichinosis yep nice [ __ ]
BBQ how do you like it tell you what
it's tough to be brothers barbecue in
Denver Colorado to English brothers well
you know what we're in travel all over
America and we're from England when
travel all over America go to the top
barbecue places culture vulture the [ __ ]
and make the best barbecue sauce and
they do it it's not change see I think
there's only two of them yep I'm Tony
Mann I'll be there soon
I'm telling you I'll be there at the end
of the month I'm at the end of April ask
Jay Jay rain-free it's right by it's
it's by the downtown Orlando mark I'm
beat downtown Jay bring it Jay [ __ ]
eat it like six times a week
okay I like it because I went to 39 in
Kansas City and can't see these some of
those were too crowded I had to turn
around really yeah you had great
barbecue in st. Louis hello barbecue
connoisseur are you I hate real vinegary
like sour like real like it's sweet dark
like a roasty barbecue sauce I like a
pig I like a barbecued pig on a paper
fan that is a lot not a pig fan not a
big fan you're not I'll have bacon of
its around
I don't like pork chops I think pigs are
cute I don't like shredded Port and my
hair I like I like the ribs now I like
the ribs and then baby yes yeah my
favorite meat problem is I don't like
the way they treat pigs so then I gotta
go then I gotta get the organic pig
that's lived outside for a while until
they turn it into that till they turn
out of that yeah that's a tough tough
life to be a pen now let it roast you
tough life to be a pig now you saw papa
shops grilling skills when I was cooking
them them them rib eyes yeah dude my
favorite things is grill drama I'm a rib
eye kicks told me a piece too
the hardest thing I took it off to see
if it was done and you ate it yeah which
is usually frowned upon around the grill
where I'm from
right penalty's usually death and why
why is that what I do I'm trying to
figure out let it cool off and by the
time I look down you eat it oh so you
want us out you were high
well [ __ ] we have talking do drogas
podcasts you sorts come over my house
for dinner right I'm like dude haven't
seen the new crib right I'm close to
Rogen I know dude you got to come over
he was cool man and I SEMATECH so hey
give me heads up cuz I'm grilling these
organic rib eyes blah blah blah hyping
them up are you a tech firm that goes
dude the spelling was way off too it's
like all [ __ ] up goes dude so high I
said oh my go at one point I go I really
need you to come and get me like I need
help sometimes you have to ask your
friend for helman sweats so chillin no I
didn't know that so I I go to his house
he picks me up now your crib there's
something very special about it because
it's big but it's cozy
so whoever that [ __ ] architect is
knows what they're doing
I had to text your girl this is so weird
yeah I had to texture your girl because
I don't think I don't think in my
fifty-two years I have ever seen anybody
that could a homekeeper I've never seen
anything like it
I'm talking about of a [ __ ] and like
I'm talking about I'm talking about
every like you want you can't buy taste
every detail on that house has been
considered she probably did it in how
long I want to take we've been there
since what second week of February so so
that takes people here especially that
size yeah not only that dude not only
that there is not I went to her closet
it's like someone staged everything for
Architectural Digest there is not
anything out of place I looked at her I
went how are you doing this she goes I'm
obsessive I'm literally obsessed yeah I
tell you what happened when we were
showing the house that I sold in Santa
Monica the agents would come they went
we have to know who's your stager who
was the stage in this house it's your
girl for no agent would go well it's the
owners the owners do they go she does is
she's amazing you know who she worked
for so now she's getting her her
freaking I would hire her efficacious I
would hire interior design
and then the the the company that sold
the house wants to hire her for interior
design he's phenomenal [ __ ] ever be a
mom she's she's truly talented calm down
but I mean and also she doesn't like how
to bring her down you know it's all
right she doesn't even have help she
does on her own
yeah it's nuts dude I mean daddy's on
the road break-in his bags they come on
man come on bro no bro
you're breaking you back out there yeah
keep my keep my thread I'll be more keep
Homebase keep Homebase playing you love
your spot you love your neighborhood you
want you just chill and went dude I
don't leave and your son I forgot you
see I got so jealous I was there I was
high but what you were oh the person I
met the person that suffered me out was
that little boy he wanted to show you
this room oh my Chatty Cathy is built
like a Navy SEAL yeah he's ready for
buds now I told Bryan I said once you
come over and get five seating my son
he's looking for grappler all his hands
are about the size of mine he's three
years old he's got traps
he's built like Tito Ortiz I'm not
exaggerating he has the same body
he and everything like when he runs
everything moves together like this no
you know little kids are all my kids are
lanky there there's things are moving
because the children that kids like
everything moves together solid dude man
it was the cutest if you ever
god forbid perish you're sliding in I'm
sliding in so that reminds me your wife
called me today oh and I ain't I went I
knew this moment would come
oh man I said where you at yes I'm hard
right now well I swear yeah she and she
wanted information I saw you as soon as
your name popped up I went I'm coming I
knew this was coming
yeah rock hard why here at the house I'm
coming did you wet rock art that's wet
why throw it wait where you called you
in about your CBD violent yeah I was
just [ __ ] with you what do you need
no you were to stab me right in the back
in a heartbeat
some things I failed on it gimme I want
a kid I want one of those kids you you
can squeeze out okay
practice makes perfect I need a third
kid practice makes perfect
I get sucked off first though I got a
sack
well she wants CVD well I can't you
pulled back what she wanted she wants
CBD oil she was using a [ __ ] one I
said you want my sin I'm saying that
pure spectrum Pago so now you getting
Peter spec that your house once a month
it's got seven welcomes I mean I'm only
gonna charge you $6,000
that's it that's it okay that's my gift
to you six cheese six jeez
now that's an upcharge but since i'm
charge drive me nuts some days yeah
that's what I'm doing dude all right
he's charging me it's because I Drive
you little nuts just because yeah I
understand just cuz dude I understand
socks don't go with the shoes but I
don't mind you know I just like to mix
it up sometimes you mix it up I'm going
through a weird crisis right now my hair
I was shaving
that's all picture myself I thought you
know what yeah yeah you know what dude
you know I understand you know it goes
um did you uh what your boy Anthony
Pettis who's your boy how about that
I know how cool is that I mean a
knockout Wonder Boy
unbelievable and I didn't think he was
gonna do it at all I thought it was a
nightmare of a matchup for me yeah the
first round wasn't great form he's
laying some leg kicks but then the
Superman punch he's the Hall of Famer
he's a Hall of he's a [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] he did we walk his hometown finest
that's right he's from and they burned a
neighbor catch the guys that burned his
[ __ ] cars down I like his house and
cars right yeah I don't know hey it's
the cars him and his brother right yeah
which crazies his brothers a [ __ ]
stud - yeah you're Santa PEZ girl no I
have not
listen down you name's not Showtime
without pulling a dime done guy didn't
bring her that rhymes
you name it show time without pulling a
dime dance right you know I'm saying
that's right yeah by the way after I was
after I came back to Joe's studio after
you picked me up and dropped me off
still wasn't okay to drive
still wasn't okay to drives a new Tesla
Drive itself no I'm not like that so I
had to work out I had to work out what
yeah well she's do you have a problem
with her
the may sound disaster and in France we
say say own disaster that's a disaster
dude I don't can you please bring up
well J do me a favor don't click on her
as a kid throwback pictures God did get
less creepy dude but that's a listen
she's uh she's you don't get
better-looking glue say that name ain't
show time without pulling a dime done
shout-out to that guy he's he's head
talk about a comeback to talk about a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he was on a rough little
patch after he went on that Wheaties box
it wasn't fun for him now it really
wasn't Milwaukee's finest is right there
well yeah let's get off his girl okay
you don't know he comes out without
being the Danza what been with her for a
while
I'm sure hardly I don't have kids yet
just must loathe drummer and seventy at
170 nothing to lose yeah I was really
cool really really cool um yeah I get
for him it's good to see good guys doing
well man yep yeah he wasn't as shredded
as usual no but when you go up to send
me a knife to cut weight you know you're
just eating right that's right I think a
lot more guys and me jumping up that's a
nightmare away class I mean you still
got I loved when he talked about Pettis
asking you see get him ready for his
fights and he goes
they still does you ever won a fight
basking does not ever want to embarrass
myself like that yeah I'm so high on
been askin I've heard these stories
about been destroying some of the best
guys in the world for a year
Molly whopping where guys like Molly was
nothing we can do Wow absolutely nothing
there is a video of what the hell's his
name the great the great jujitsu guy
just beating Ben Askren to death
Gabriel Garcia Marcela Garcia oh really
yeah when they're rolling I mean
unbelievable Marcela guys they're just
taking his time with him and just tied
him in knots I got said I was like what
but but powerful dead that's also a
rolling that's not straight jiu-jitsu
yeah powerful dad Bob yeah you were high
as [ __ ] though man I took one hit I
don't smoke weed and you kept going Wow
and we're are we as a keyword come on
dude I was my dad
I don't remember a lot of it Johanna
wait he's not gonna come over and be all
weird is you know what no you probably
gonna tell I will I'm trying not Tigers
definitely not gonna tell I was trying
not to be weird but I knew your hide
when you grabbed that [ __ ] hot meat
off the shelf man because I jumped in an
uber oh you did get nubra huh yeah I
think I did grab that he went to dinner
that night
yeah I was still I just couldn't drive
hi I don't I don't take that chance so I
had to wait and I rode Rogen's bike I
lifted weights
I thought we has a bag we do not get
it's not like it doesn't go away no
you're not gonna work it sweat it out
I'm not know Jesus it was it was three
hours Derek and a sauna night the you
know fans always bring me weed even
though I am really not pot guy but there
was bringing a weed well Derek and the
Sun are both we do they smoke like every
night so they had this fat joint and we
stayed in a haunted hotel a very haunted
hotel and the first I slept with one
while on I was a cow not big not a big
deal slept with light on then I was like
oh I don't have to leave till noon
tomorrow
I'm smoked a little weed with these guys
smoked a big old fat doobie bad idea I
was so paranoid in my room I got zero
sleep zero sleep had sleep with TV
loudest [ __ ] all the lights on I was so
scared man I was just when you get high
and get paranoid yeah sort of thing
about ghosts and I'm like maybe I should
just look up what these guys saw didn't
you read these all this [ __ ] about what
NBA play cuz all NBA the Cavs were there
when we were there all the MLB Steam
stay there so when you looked up what
those guys were reporting I start
getting super paranoid do you smoke weed
every night no never
I can't remember last time I smoked weed
yeah I take CBD oil genet which is non
psychoactive ratio tha zero you rarely I
meet you I never might eat see my system
was probably I don't even know last time
was when we were on Rogan it was you me
and Eddie and I was drinking yeah I got
so [ __ ] up definitely shouldn't drove
home
that's Jeff I should've drawn like eight
minutes but it's not eight minutes I
would either tank but definitely should
have drove yeah yeah that's but I also I
don't like smoking because I'm a control
freak so I don't like feeling out of
control how and then I'll so I have some
[ __ ] and
I mean that I want to say yeah but I
feel term I self yes well but I feel
like when I smoke weed I'm just gonna
blur it all out I'm gonna one night when
I do a book I'm gonna put in there but I
want to waste some vodka some high well
at one point I was talking to Joe we
were having a great conversation and the
weed hit and he started to he started to
disappear into a tunnel are you in a
tunnel and why can't why do I have no
peripheral vision and why are you
echoing why does your voice sound
echoing that's how high oh no how you're
super what's us like it's not like Joe
has that normal we'd not have that
normal push is what does he have that's
like is how long he's been doing [ __ ]
the mary-jane so he's not gonna have
your normal run-of-the-mill high school
[ __ ] crazy is that psychoactive Joe
Rogan's it's borderline host let's take
a hit on my cattitude I mean there's you
can get super quiet cuz I get
self-conscious I'm gonna rattle off some
weird [ __ ] or I'll never do it again cuz
I got a drive so can't do it I live so
close I get a little high with the fight
campaign this is fun I think there's
sort of fight Sunday is a fight Sunday
Saturday I think in a while there's
another Sunday Sunday's are the best
days it's time there's a great we got to
do a Sunday so much fun um yeah man I
it's it was it was fun but I think it I
think it will shot a whiskey now before
I go on stage one shot of whiskey one
beer that's my new thing that I uh I
kept looking in your fridge you don't
know this because you were putting Tiger
to bed and I kept going to your fridge
opening it and then closing it I
remember doing that kept going best
times did you grab anything didn't grab
a thing well I was like is there any
cheese in here I got drinks for days lot
of liquid a lot of liquid in there again
like my fridge couldn't be more
organized the fridge couldn't be morale
and had my drinks bro yeah I feel like a
baller if I open up my fridge and it's
filled with beverages
since I was a kid I remember my mom
would go go shopping and she would let
you put everything away I will open that
fridge and if there were cokes and
[ __ ] sprites and frescoes it was like
packed yeah like how we're balling mom
yeah
so this day five drinks I feel like I'm
doing something right you got all
socially interesting things in there
good drinks
good drinks do ya now yes oh there you
are there you have I don't think you
needed any other day the funny thing
about that is you've now at 36 have kind
of what you need your house and
everything I don't know if it gets
better
it just gets different all downhill
right from here bro is there is there
more than you need do you need more than
a little I mean I don't know dude how do
you do no I don't think so what do you
do do you don't think so now I'm headed
to our nation's capital this weekend yes
you are you're going to Washington DC my
old stomping grounds where I went to
college that's right dude Americans
there right yeah maybe I'll go to your
campus and rough some people up what do
you mean just shove them around finding
the Dean and just piss on him is that
right for you first time I saw my father
well actually second time I saw my
father try to fight a guy was in front
of my college why and my father has a
bad temper I think it's because he grew
up poor and he's high rashim he's a big
guy and whatever it is you don't have
the best temper no I don't know I have a
bad time yeah I have actually have a
misstep both have noses yeah yeah I will
that's what I always say I say my temper
can get to me to a point we do don't you
see me where I'm ready to fight yeah
baby I'm gonna fight now do the jail
time I'm gonna go I don't like bullies I
don't like I don't like injustice it
makes me [ __ ] murderous but what are
you did you notice I'm afraid all the
time and I'm gonna get mad I that all
goes out the window I'm like all right
here goes but my father's saying with me
we're a seed starts and then it starts
going bad yeah I had that last night in
sleep yeah really
you and I are like that like I get I'll
get a seed and it'll start to germinate
and there's a big black tree I can't
sleep that's that woke up one in the
morning I was like oh and something hit
me about one of the bits I'm doing so I
was writing that down and then hit me
went oh yeah blah blah blah forgot to do
that like I wonder why that happened and
it's like oh he meant to do that that's
like oh yeah and then I was like and he
can't sleep I threw the more I'm like
this guy man I'm gonna call him in the
morning tell him how I feel that's what
happened wrote a long email you
oh yeah that's what happened he started
it's weird how that happens my my dad in
front of my college a guy we're crossing
the street and this big scary dude how
old was this all hello I'm 19
okay scary when I'm 19 my dad is
probably 72 ho well he was probably 40
in his 40s right and the guy starts he
screaming at us but the windows were
rolled up but he's screaming at us out
and is like Abba murderously I like that
white guy yeah and when I see that I
went that guy's crazy
let's keep walking before I know what
the [ __ ] is going on my dad did you dad
serve yes he was a Maria oh yeah yeah
good luck Murray Murray a United States
Marine
yeah yeah and then went on to do other
things yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] also
Wisconsin farm boys debts also grew up
having a work yeah you did with this
hand
super dis plan yeah construction oh yeah
all that stuff like it it was a boy war
no money no money dad who was not there
you know yeah dad was basically drunk
dad dad who checked out Dadda was never
there that makes you angry
yeah I understand so my dad that I had a
very different childhood than my dad
yeah little Lord Fauntleroy so he goes
up to the window finally squint he goes
right up to the guys window and he's
going ha ha ha ha ha and he's fake
laughing he's trying to get the guy out
then he's going come on Jada come on out
it's a sociopath thing I'm like dude
you're trying to fight a total psycho
the guy was every bit as big but he just
sees red he sees it all goes back to his
that's his dad you know we all have
those things
it was incredible old-school man right
oh I blow this driver to lustrum forever
and it just reminded me when it last
time I think it was my 13th I remembers
my birthday is my 13th birthday my dad
used to have a terrible temper it's
where Jay gets it he's if it got to that
still this number is not great but it
used to be so bad fly off the hinges and
this car kept cutting around the highway
225 its car kept cutting
in Denmark if Gunness so then my dad's
cutting him my stepmom and then me and
my brother in the back so I'm probably I
don't know twelve my brother's 1314 and
they keep kindness my dad's cutting him
so they're doing this thing where
they're trying to make each other wreck
through here in front slam on the brakes
getting front side on the brakes then
they both my dad's point in late like to
get over the exit they both get off the
X and um I mean I'm terrified like what
I've never seen my dad so round I'm like
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen so we get
off the exit mexic is the one that goes
up so goes up highway huge drop so they
go up and this guy gets out of the car
my dad gets out I'll never forget cuz my
dad all the years was doing Taekwondo by
all the years I mean like thirty but
he's like this huh you wanna [ __ ] go
you want a [ __ ] goat he's like this
like a dhania troll uncle dying like
Bobby's yeah and he is like a and I'm
the guy had a leather coat on he said
yeah you wanna [ __ ] go and then they
might be like throw some my dad grab
just I just remember that's missing a
finger when that [ __ ] grabs them and
then just picks him up and puts him over
the edge of the highway why I'm like
yeah he's got that shop strength yeah
and then he lets him go
they're talking [ __ ] and [ __ ] shark
eyes dull smile goes around the car and
while the guys talking [ __ ] to my dad
Jay kicks him in the nuts from behind
oh he's 14 I'm outside the Clark I'm
outside the car
I don't ever forget the guy saying
something in Jay you know he doesn't
know yours you [ __ ] Jew didn't make
sense
Jason Joe does you [ __ ] think of it
think of the demon you're a demon of a
40 no they kick the man in the Nazi oh
you [ __ ] Jew we're all you might as
like we'll talk about that later
I had to [ __ ] in the car my dad gets in
there I'm scrying I'm so scared so
scared stuff move on him I'm so I'm 12
or 13 my dad gets a car he had a
Cadillac STS silver he takes his [ __ ]
palm and this is where the tie clinic
came in and goes [ __ ] yes yeah yeah to
the rearview mirror and the whole window
goes
oh my oh my gosh that mom called the
cops called the cops cuz you so scared
that my dad's gonna kill them throw my
horse that's terrifying
and then I'll never forget we come home
and it's like it was my birthday I got a
pack of proline NFL cards and I got a
Jim Kelly autograph and I forget that I
was all happy about that
but I remember the whole family was like
shook we come back your own goes to the
rooms and my dad had to do the dad thing
came to my room knocking noise ik well
talk to you about what happened today
that's not don't do that not the way you
conduct yourself
well my I was like okay I didn't know
what to tell my son cuz he was getting
bullied by two kids and I can tell hold
seven but they were like kind of tough
and my son's pretty tall that's such a
bad doesn't fall for the age yeah I
really told I'm feeling super tall yeah
Todd and everybody I'm huh yeah it's big
and um and I and I was like well yeah
and I was like um and he's got a temper
though my son - just like you yeah and
he but I teach him a little boxing and
you know wrestling but he I guess he
went up to those kids and at a party and
he wanted to go home and my my my wife
was like no you're staying and you're
gonna play with his kids were there yeah
and so what he did was he the one kid
one time said you're a jerk and then my
son
apparently went up and said hey I'm
gonna kick your sweet ass kick your
sweet ass if you call me a jerk again
hey turn the other Kenny goes and I'm
gonna kick your sweet ass if you call me
first of all only fight your sweet ass
because you don't want to kick your
sweet ass it's beautiful hilarious most
funny thing I've ever seen kids beat the
[ __ ] up no they ended up they well they
stomp them out they back down and then
they ended up playing and from now
they're all friends it's so like a
little bit of a gangster
I didn't realize my son's also again
it's so heartbreaking when you hear that
kids again bully is there anything worse
she [ __ ] me up for nothing can do it
[ __ ] me up for a week I was I was
frantic about it I don't know what to do
my wife's way better about these things
she's way more calm and she's more
involved I was I'm gonna go talk to the
teachers cuz out and he's a shame yeah
but I - I
that now happened in my son your son's
not what you didn't make friends your
friends not yeah well that's the thing
well if you don't make for stealing up
the right group a friend
I couldn't bear my son to be long dude
there's nothing worse I meant when I
switched schools from Aurora middle
school to prairie middle school from
sixth seventh grade I had no friends I
used to cry every night my dad's like
just wait you're gonna make friends
you're gonna make friends that made my
first friend and you and I need for
Alice to defy my sleeve I don't do well
on the road I'll get done him be my
hotel room just call random people like
hey how's it going man like who [ __ ]
this but its job what's up man like you
don't talk in seven years I know just
scrolling through the old rolodex what
are you doing man like dude it's 2:00
a.m. oh yeah yeah no doubt no doubt no
doubt on yeah you doing out there Roger
out the weather out there I'm cold huh
you know I hear you man yeah I'm not
good enough there's that um there's that
that movie called the lives of others
it's an amazing movie about the German
secret police in East Germany and this
did when the wall came down communism
was no longer in Germany unified those
Stasi they were called the Stasi the
secret police they had files and
everybody they had nothing to do and one
of the things that this guy would
there's a scene in the movie where the
guy who was ahead of the Stasi and he
used to say he said well artists are not
a problem they say what I mean because
well I've always found that when you
take them and you keep them in a Cell
alone for about a year or maybe two
years just leave them here alone when
they come out they can never make art
again so that doesn't delight oh yes you
take the light out of them that's the
kind of people that you have to that's
that was who is in power that's what
happens whenever any government gets
super powerful they're in the business
of control you do whatever they can dude
yeah you know usually my brother
couldn't go because his wife had their
company party here when I was in
Milwaukee so I brought Derek in a song
with me didn't they're just comedy heads
man they know everything they know
everyone about comi so we sit around we
set out coffee shop for three hours time
out comedy so come out bit some about
the Comedy Store for you the time about
yeah that's that's the best part of the
journey
super important man it's great it's a
really important
also writing I mean I spent so much time
in Kansas City writing there's nothing I
like more than you don't meet me and
those guys get together every Thursday
and Riley
every Thursday we get together right for
two hours oh dude yeah that's so good
come to my house we do a workshop that's
a huge every Thursday that's beautiful
good for you man I can't I can't usually
right with anybody but I do think
there's a lot of bouncing that like dude
right when we start laughing it's great
great idea no it's you and I said when
we were doing finally kids live unite
skip gala but what's funny to me is me
at Rob's do we have a weird since you
remember Ryan would think something is
like we'd be on the ground cackling like
hyenas then we try it like crickets
later it gets chip [ __ ] [ __ ] great
I get a big nut [ __ ] y'all I thought
that was hilarious
yeah come we're died raise at work yeah
that just happened sometimes you know
I'll tell you what last night I told
chin this I'm below the belt the perfect
[ __ ] night for me out a nice there's
this Mahal ins pizza I mean the best
like New York slice pizzas New York
dough order a pepperoni large pepperoni
pizza watch some American Idol wash it
down with a nice fresca
that's a [ __ ] that's living brother
you like Miss American I'll do set
fresca twice now you like yourself we
never had a friend my mom was a fan so I
think I was a fan
your bone structure cuz because Mom
ashab ain't weak no momma sabudana oh
yeah mama Shabba dunk on you so I'm
thinking you might might have a right to
know I know your dad speak but but more
slender he doesn't have your same bro
well Salem husky like my MA no your
mom's not honey your mom's a beautiful
ass your mom's a beautiful woman
actually yeah but she's shy when
choosing she's athletic like you can see
she's got but she's powerful don't come
to your mom light in the ass that's all
I'm trying to say like Brian I still get
my humor from them now your mom has a
crush on the ball but she and I have a
thing going and you hook up with mine
when my mom and Denver we've been over
this all I'm saying is that there's you
touch my mom and aunt nubby I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up and I'll be a mom wanna put
my hands on you listen but you touched
my nubby listening I'm gonna [ __ ] your
teeth the three of us go out and have
some wine and daddy starts holding court
and then one thing leads to you I get a
picture
I'm beeline straight to you I'm not
saying I'm gonna stack mommy and nubby
I'm not say I would never do that
I'm not I say I would never do that I'm
just trying to say that there that
sometimes don't make me [ __ ] your sister
you got hey what the [ __ ] is us back me
in a corner hey make me [ __ ] your sister
what yeah bro also do it listen me I
don't exactly really live listen to me
this is not statment w my mom listen I
would never do that
it's that bro I'm saying I said I'd say
three consenting adults I'm saying damn
st. I know that dude three consenting
adults everybody called the [ __ ] down
but less an angel I know she is so don't
say stack I didn't he said step I didn't
say I wouldn't
you said step my I didn't mean to hit I
said I'm not going to have he's a saint
I know but the three of us if your
liver-spotted hands off let's get along
and we're consenting adults if we go out
and have some wine or you're not in the
picture where the hell are you you're
not even a loving son say man tell your
sis listen take it easy right take it
easy stop threatening man sex with my
family members you stop you said stack
might know me of my mom I don't know why
says dang locked out I don't know why
did the mile-high gangbang oh yeah
you're the one who said it
my gang man hey I'll to do I'm out of
breath oxygen oxygen a lot of pumpin do
you want a lot of humping do but large
pizza and a [ __ ] fresca and some
American Idol America gets me to choke
up every time man just hits the [ __ ]
nerves a [ __ ] spin around how long
Halla season 13 or 14 phenomenal and it
was and you know where it came from
Elin your mother's hometown oh yeah
2002 wow that's almost 20 years kids
Katy Perry makes 25 million dollars a
year from that I think she's rested guys
and she's so hot am I wrong
she's pretty hot a little weird I hate
that string show about her all the time
but she's great you all of course she
does but let me see her breakdown here
do you get better looking though I think
she's she is ridiculously talented and
hot why is she crying here I want to see
this
no so
dude the performance with the blind guy
rentals about that blind girl that you
start crying like a real [ __ ] remember
they do they're in the group phase now
and the three group of the four group
members put glasses on Shiva him glasses
so she could have a could experience
what she sees they can barely see but so
in the group rounds they give you one
day to learn the song
you got all harmonize together she can't
see so she can't read the words so to
try and teach her though it's
heartbreaking to try and teach her the
words and she can't learn them and
they're like hours before she's like I
just I don't learn this way I don't know
what to do so they have her mom come and
her mom's like just give me an hour with
her goes with the mom they just show a
picture of her mom like helping her out
heartbreaking and then she learns it and
chills and real trauma that's real oh
dude you gotta see it I wonder if this
is it I do cry over this stuff I'm
looking about me a little cold won't
stop Katy Perry from slant no does it
have the highlight of the oh wait Katy
Perry sings there does she
oh they they go cuz she's sick and Luke
Bryan goes do you think you could sing
fireworks and she [ __ ] goes let's see
that not she insane but she's super sick
when you make it forget about it st.
firework with that in there
she's such a beast I bet she is such a
freak in the sheets she isn't she's got
a sense of humor oh she's old so you can
still sing she's hilarious on there hmm
okay well I'm gonna have to go down that
rabbit hole I'm gonna have to go down
the rabbit hole I wish they would show
the blind girl I can't want to be able
to show that that can't watch it yeah
it's crazy man I'm too much of a [ __ ]
about that sir yeah yeah that one had me
choking up with my pizza I tried a
little bit today oh yeah save it for
Christ's I'll save it for I don't have
psoriasis anymore I'll say no not my
hairline bra do them bro what's up man
oh I'm sorry I don't know what you don't
I like to like we were so plenty of all
demons so I like like connect you know
yeah well no you're being quietly
insulting okay [ __ ] damn it I did an
interview for Forbes magazine and on an
end
I mentioned Brendan and I mentioned it I
like talking about how I'm proud of my
friend of doing a special and it's on
Showtime and he's and we're you know and
I've learned a lot about social media
marketing and I just know I did way
better that oh you're welcome and all
that and he goes like this I get this
from my friend I get this that's
interesting
hold on let me see where it is oh my god
oh you know tell me you you plays hey
man mention you in for just mentioning
you and your special on Forbes interview
Brennan you guys oh cool 50 oohs okay
hopefully the 75 year olds are still
reforms tuned if that's all I guess like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
it's so fun that's what I get from him
oh my god wait that's what got you
emotional the Forbes no no uh I'll save
it for okay else did you find the chin
no I can find it the oh this will do it
so have it I won it all that that's
right this I
I know not to go there no the guy who
wrote that I want that way yeah go back
to suite I thought I saw it
all right there American I'll recap
there it is I think the video was on
that one though
yeah she's so blind so Alejandra I
Rhonda I'm offensive honest that's like
saying I'm she's so protective I'm so
pregnant or she's half pregnant
offensive well I mean she's blonde she's
well there you go
get ready that's a blind one on the left
great song she can't read the lyrics to
shark tank she can't learn like the rest
of ya breaks your heart man I wanna hug
her right me too
she can sing he can sing you just hang
Andra day yeah watch eyes mm-hmm it's
cool all supportive there though now
remember you get what you use 24 hours
to learn it she's 20 she's a child and
if you don't do well nope in this round
you get sent home and I watch mom to
help her learn gives me chills man hey
shout-out to moms like that look at the
mom helping her though I love her me see
the mom takes her she knows how she can
learn
Creason our me too man just so you know
you see the chemistry with all of them
it's not like this there is ug chaos
really ruins out for themselves
now watch them watch them see how they
have the goggles on she made them so
they can see like her see how well they
work together though this [ __ ] makes me
me to believe in God yeah for real
I know it's special she's gonna be a
star
damn dude I'm so glad you let me see
that
no man you [ __ ] that [ __ ] rule that's
how powerful real drama man you know you
find me a movie that gets makes you want
to help people
yeah and it makes me want to sing and
you and I makes me want to start how
about one of your eyes come on you do it
with one on down
tell me see not know tell me why I can't
I can't get the world
see y'all touch bring up the lyrics
please tell me why we're he's so yeah is
that in sing yeah yeah oh dude yeah you
are my fire the one okay take the desire
believe when I say I want it that way
gone but we are too how does it go to
the worlds apart can't reach to your
heart
guys wrote a song when you should have
you sang this song before I was younger
yeah ah for sure do the country version
yes Wow on it that way
but do it blind so you can feel me why
ain't nothin but a heartache tell me why
ain't nothin but a mistake sorry dude I
get [ __ ] carried away there the
octopus will they call hello version
occupied you sang it dude mmm well with
the batch which is what's crazy is
though I watch this documentary on the
Backstreet Boys cuz I'm way too into
them there it's crazy how talented they
actually are yeah yeah well to get that
audition they had to have chops they had
to be able to sell non audition they
kind of like took the best from the best
and put them together I mean they're all
nice I mean they're all they're all had
already they're you know I want to that
way live from the diamond theater yeah
click on that one let me hear these
[ __ ]
my favorite is dayj in the middle bro
that he's a cool voice sounds like mine
he sounds jus like him
you didn't have the same here actually
I'm singing for 20 years these guys
do dirt relevant more now than ever
they're huge
he has a problem with its vocal cords
you can tell
Nick's still doing the damn thing though
his brother suck your dick now come on
man it's no he well good-looking kid
hell yeah he is you know he started the
band we is 14 Brian aces yeah take it
easy Spacey so young Scooby space key
areas okay he's a little off
okay the law used to be a drug addict
yeah he was not a great song by the way
but so I like this life sorry dude you
don't like this solo you're AB Europe
basically a fanboys you are correct
right I mean so I understand how you
have the whole thing I don't know I
would love to see you sitting with all
those guys just a giant dressed just
fine and I wish saving our cut now
Brendan Chavez you come out with a mic
mr. chair now Brendan boy that guy's had
some work done and he looks like a
vampire I'm sorry are you off the set of
true love
yeah he's had some work done no you are
you from the set of True Blood he's had
his eyes down though has yeah he's had
what Bryan Callen needs dude have you
seen their new video where they're with
their family dad man some did not pick
right sometimes you pick a nice peach
and over the years
entropy we all get older whoa
Nick's still doing it yeah he is the
other guys like so the other guys kind
of problem this vocals yeah he has like
lumps on it or some show no they're gone
no they go on tour and it's a prob yeah
he's got nodes JT got nodes no notes
have you ever had anything like that
never had problems luckily Jen do you
miss those days being a boy band I miss
one I loved singing that much do not
love singing anymore I do but I mean
performing there was a time when I loved
performing you don't love you don't miss
performing not that much no just making
music is good
yeah but performing live that onion
don't need that to do we could do it
when we do when Brian I do stand-up
together in Vegas you should open up
like a hundred percent I'll do it one
Jack Shepard does it on his pocket he
has a he has a guy open up his life
shows the guy who plays the song on that
show really the guy is really really
good that could be you chin let's do it
what song he is seeing though this
something more difficult really this is
not legit this oh wow yeah my bad John
Mayer I'll get I like it I like it a lot
like Bruno Bruno Mars which saw moi
24-karat in the Versace since I love
that saw someone oh wow traffic or
remember we hope that can bring people
kicking in after a while
[Music]
ji-yong no you no you no no I don't know
how you don't know that so you know you
know when the beat starts kicking in
that's the best part of it
is what chin wants to sing before we do
stand-up watch watch down no I get it
but you know I think makes a lot more
update but to try to [ __ ] in Vegas you
hire professionals out there chin Doody
do this a higher professional for you
Thomas Eakins okay done how tall is he
five feet he's T so small I've won if
that I'll tell you a story when this is
over about him that I heard this weekend
about a guy who worked with him so it's
slow here right mounted gun in live in
purchased name I'll tell you the town I
heard about have you seen when he's a
kid no he's a killer he's the best
number one
put your pinky fingers to the moon you
do that one chin washes you trying to
[ __ ] Vegas man that's the part I do
bursar yeah this is what people are like
wild to get riled up ramping up man si
Jin now remember you know you have all
the smoke and [ __ ] in the life lets me
just you take it all slow and they're
expecting to see some dick jokes at a
fly where would American music be
without the immigrant experience you
have it shut up so you know oh I do love
it great stand-up can't we get another
one chin now you saying whatever you
want actually I think it'd be great if
we yeah but maybe have to slow a song
than over oh yeah
we come out in the end and start dancing
a little bit that'd be great Oh back and
forth was a Bruno Mars oh this my boy
Matt whose Gucci Mane's personal
photographer when gucci mane five five
that's funny when gucci mane did his
video with Bruno Mars
they asked Matt to shoot Bruno - you
saying there's a whole team and he's
saying you cannot collaborate with Bruno
he has to sign off on everything and he
has to be the direct he does it all from
cameras angles no pictures can be taken
unless he approves it first you can't
take pictures until he's picture already
like everything you can't do anything
without his approval tomato from cameras
angles Cory the dancing the lighting he
does it all he's so much smaller than
Taylor Swift is that to us it's a real
picture - I tell us what their dragon
though yeah that's all she dragon she's
bout she white dragon nah she's six
seven no I don't think she's dragon no
but in those high heels she might be
yeah try six four knows no she's hot ten
right don't chin loves Taylor Swift
chin you'd like to have a be rude I'm
teaching how to sing
of course she's awesome you like white
girls chin if it's telling ya yeah I
knew it
five ten so with heels on she's six one
six one mmm big girl she's yeah yeah
your to line the astroturf no yeah my
insects not my type that's how she gets
older gets a little thicker
yeah shootie just a full rack of ribs a
day you could do something yeah not my
type and i'll find her sexy but she's uh
there's something sexy about her - yeah
I guess by the way she's 30 she's 29
years old yeah
oh she is she's older well too young 17
well that would be 15 years ago Brian
yes she was yeah she's a guy it's a
beautiful girl she's beautiful but
superpower she dated super powerful I
don't know she is a gorgeous tough one
to date I feel like my dad Jin LUN I'm
more of a Selena Gomez lot more Demi
Lovato yeah my eyes like pick out of
three I'm more of a cardi B to be honest
for telling the truth here yeah yeah
more cardi B for over cardi B yeah you
doing the comedy store tomorrow
yeah I am Brian oh yeah three sets dude
meet you great Thursday show in Philly
so get your tickets it oh I sound super
excited I like the anomaly's I can't
wait I love Philly I love helium so
you're doing two shows on Thursday now
is you're 32 I've never done that to
show stars they - satisfied - so sad by
Saturday me yeah but I'm writing and
come have a new I have a shut up dude
remember what I think so oh my god yeah
sure my friends there you go what I go
what I saying is that shut up dude
remember when uh when I say remember
like last year like in Calgary in Dublin
in a bunch of areas I'd do three shows
in a day and you're like dude I'm
telling you stop doing that
God Dubai that third show the into the
third show your zombie not worth it
zombie yeah they wanted to do that
where was I Kaymer I was like man do I
don't think so chin what'd you do this
weekend dude uh not much just
I saw Korean barbeque dip in some meat
and some cheese yes pork jowls you went
to cut oh no I'm just thinking about the
cheese and meat you like cheese and meat
yeah and cream barbeque so good we
stopped in a Korean barbecue not here at
least the best place is here oh yeah we
was the Korean barbecue in Seattle
somewhere yeah let's go to all of you
let's go Bellevue cream bar where's the
best place what's it called right now I
think for for the vast majority people a
pair of beat quarters wears quarters at
downtown LA or downtown I like Koreatown
far it's not that far
if it's actually closer than downtown oh
it is what's the next closest or
anything open they're all in the same
area that's the thing all the good stuff
is yeah you go to cut hmm every now and
then yeah Korean barbecues one of those
things you kind of go with a group of
people it's lonely eating if you go to
Korean barbecue by yourself it doesn't
happen but uh Swiss cheese dip my Swiss
cheese is a very Korean modulus it's
like like a nacho cheese that's like a
bunch of different cheeses mixed
together hey you mean too so it's a case
that's like a fondue Russian was a case
of wacko okay so cheese fondue and
raclette see other places never called
the melting pot where it's fondue he's
just fun do you put meats in those out
here it's delicious
they have melting pot here mm-hmm oh
it's a franchise yes laughs [ __ ] them
like proper fondue with what is reclaim
cheese it's a type of cheese a Swiss
type of Swiss cheese not Swiss but a
type of cheese from Swiss or [ __ ] did
you put on potatoes the law but I
thought you dipped it in you take the
potato dip it in go ahead and show how
it's made it'll it'll it'll knock your
dick in the dirt I might like he's
cramping up oh I've seen this on TV a
few times
it's the bit the cheese and you wrote
[ __ ] you heat it up and it melts onto
your potatoes oh cool man potatoes au
gratin you mean up now it's a very
special thing that's forwarded chin yeah
well he's making grilled cheese just
take that right there just shave it all
melted Jesus Christ on your potatoes and
that's he just melts the edge yeah I'll
tell you right now you're gonna burden
the [ __ ] out of your mouth that's hot
lava for two minutes it's so good yeah
it's just where's that ad I don't know
what I need to go now this is in London
London Street food rock clap oh it's
crazy and Ron HIV has a live on that I
[ __ ] it up with the chives dude that's
[ __ ]
back in the day potatoes throw those
into the ground and let my potatoes and
dairy live on it yeah it does look nice
yeah how can I switch other oh wow
that looks better and it's really no not
just cheese though you know [ __ ]
that's not Joe cheese oh we all gooey oh
jeez oh Jesus discuss who think about it
it's so good it's my favorite food she's
cheating my favorite food yeah for real
I think it's my favorite food cheese I
like cheese well I'm all set on this man
sure you went Korean barbecue chin yeah
cat what'd you do work work and then
Universal Studios on Sunday oh you and
your man went yeah it was fun would you
guys was it busy kids are great so you'd
be careful ah a Spring Break I think is
like on the very like last week of when
Spring Break would be for schools so it
was pretty uh empty actually when you go
did you get on the bus where are the
Train where the tour yeah and you see
y'all named know the guy
you know the guy from psycho Oh after
you with a knife that actor has to do
that over and over again where he comes
in dates yeah no he has a new bait so
stone comes walking towards you with his
knife and he's staring after you
and I was like that's a terrible job
sometimes it tough it's tough yeah yeah
what about the guy when you I don't do
this up the back drafting the back
that's so old school there's a bit you
were in the movie backdraft
I think Mel Gibson with that the white
backdraft
backdraft was uh it was on Billy Baldwin
it was this was in there
it was but anyways there's a back
backdraft Universal Studios and there
would be a fire and you would go through
it but a guy would come out like alright
guys we gotta get going there's a fire
and I remember even at a young age being
like wow that guy has to do that all day
and I felt bad for him yeah yeah this
was the ride yeah sometimes acting is
like like I love Bruce I like Bruce
Buffer he's a great guy but I saw his
Instagram and he was bring him out he's
a terrible actor about do you CT Ortiz
no but all you're gonna love this but
Bruce I get to cry for a role and he
posted a picture I cannot see that zero
to the audition know it bTW Ortiz
Instagram page taking over me me me the
one with tears in his eyes oh yeah up
your brow got in the roll man got into
the part he's crying blood the tears of
well now you had to have real tears dude
the tears are paying from deep within
okay good friend Tito Jalen yeah doing
some acting man
God does not weird at all
what she's got a big head it's a big
[ __ ] tough guy I'll go see anyone who
Oh Bruce Buffer let me see Bruce
bluffers it's all AG I have no idea
Brian was talking about it
they just he whisper Friday given they
gave him it's on his IEG this is not
fair but they gave myself you know yeah
they ever forgot damage in and robust
and they gave him a free tuxedo and
idiot dad you know how you give it a
shot out you know and it's honor hi
everybody I just want to thank my King a
babe my exclusive Taylor's for this view
beautiful black classic tuxedo they made
for me for the national show tonight
we're here in Nashville for the UFC I'm
feeling a little double O seven inch and
we're gonna have a great show tonight so
big cheers to my king and babe thanks
guys you're the best I that's this thing
though right yeah it's just like it for
me you can't though you can't do it
there Bruce but now that Bruce Buffer
worthless it's it's almost like an
infomercial type of vibe he's great he's
great
well the UFC would not be the same
without Bruce Buffer he's awesome
hilarious is it great he's a good
[ __ ] guy man he's a truly a good guy
I've had long talks with that guy it's
such a good person um well you can also
do the splits remember when he was at
our podcast but he just splits right on
the table I was like you [ __ ] kidding
me my guy thought he Fox I [ __ ] yeah
he said he's actually I'm just say men
muscular guy - no he's telling that game
no not at all
but he's a big boy all right Oh what's
this so Gary Owens created this video
yesterday about an incident that
happened at Delta with his wife and
daughter so this morning my wife and
daughter were flying from Cincinnati
Ohio to San Francisco California on
Delta 7:20 a.m.
Gabey 21 so they they tell everybody
line up for first so my wife gets in
line and the guy working the gate at b21
Cincinnati Airport asked my wife are you
in first and my wife said yeah I am and
then my wife said are you not gonna ask
the guy behind me and he goes no well I
said why he said cuz I don't feel like
it
not my wife's a black lady the guy
behind her was a white dude and the
ticket agent was a white dude but he
asked the black lady are you in first
but not the white dude so Delta I have
almost three million miles with you when
you see this lady
as my wife she flies first don't ask all
right well I've heard some stories about
him you know Delta what tried dyeing
skin black no but what were you gonna
say um this is what Delta is gonna do
huh no doubt seen go Delta
oh you have 3 3 million miles don't fly
Delta they do Airlines couldn't give two
[ __ ] complaining to Delta on I love it
when comics do it all the time
oh it's especially daliyah all the time
complaining about you flights
dude though I can't emphasize enough how
those airlines don't keep it okay don't
fly us don't there's six years I want to
feel his his wrath I do feel like if
they said that to my wife I'd be and she
was black I'd be probably be really
pissed too I would make video probably
showing it no can you omit I think he's
trying to be very like okay Delta yeah
what girls flying Delta it was an
[ __ ] it might have been an [ __ ]
Mexican right that's the black person
much yeah you want to be but it might
have been a guy who's having a day you
know I mean a Delta employee of the how
many I mean look up how many employees
are work for Delta yes our
representation of Delta I say set the
reputation of that guy guys that guy
could over South yes you can work for
Delta United I flew I flew spirit
airline on the way here
are you the cheapest person the whoa cuz
I want to get back early you did you
fool you flying into no I I had to fight
on on on Delta I think but it was
stopping in Denver and I wanted to fly
straight from eighty six thousand
employees you're gonna have some bad
apples so there you have a few races
apples yeah out of it are you gonna have
a few people so so in spirit
I decided fly back early so I don't like
fight and get his spirit right so I get
spirit so depressing here said there's a
guy I've actually got happened to him
black and he goes uh he had he was
having a problem there was a he was just
he was trying to be polite but he goes
I'm never flying the guys helping me and
he goes I'm never flying
spirit again he kind of said under his
breath and the guy helped me went like
this I swear
he goes that's okay just like that
because that's okay
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] I was like
damn this is because there's only like
six Airlines and you have to fly there's
they have such a monopoly I have such a
strong wall I'm never flying I have
three million points Delta goes cool man
yeah because when we're the only direct
flight to Atlanta next week and you have
to be there and you're because what
because of random employee asks your
wife she first-class not gonna fly yeah
we don't give a [ __ ] yeah and also the
it doesn't mean the guy was racist he
when she said are you aren't you gonna
ask him right - it felt like he was
being challenged there's a chance he
could've been like you're being me and I
mean but also but also who knows the
context maybe maybe people tried sneak
and I'm I've done this before where I
don't have board and group a and I try
snake it on yeah and they go are you
sure you're a and I go pretty sure I eat
the front goes and they all dude yet
what are you I'm like see like yeah get
the [ __ ] back so I could have been a
random thing where he's like are you
sure your first class and she was like
yeah dumbass you know him I don't know
the situation so I don't know carry on
but III because I do the road and I know
lots of clubs and owners and things I
hear things but I've heard I've heard
he's a he's a volatile guy let's just
put it that way I've heard he's he can
tend to be you know what I then agree
you know what might one of my favorite
things to do is when I go to comedy club
I'm at for a few days I ask who have you
had in recently how did they sell who's
been a problem out of all the years
who's been a prophet and they can I tell
you they trip like birds if you're a
shitty person yeah yeah I mean it's well
known around the circles wow I they do
that different wow that guy looks
terrible yeah I don't know hey I don't
know Gary Owen I don't know me and who
knows if that if that employees racist
yeah you know it could have been a
coincidence he just asked the black
person again I've snuck on the planes
where I didn't have a III used to know
what your Airlines I would they wouldn't
check in which I I forget these days and
I get caught sometimes it's so
embarrassing we get the front and you're
like yeah thank you a
and you're like oh and I go like this
girl I got goddamnit
oh I see I don't know what's going on
right it's so embarrassing
I'm sure he's a good guy out [ __ ] now
I don't really click on his wife through
the far right chin I guess ever married
a while I ride they have kids and so she
stays in shape yeah she looks good woman
he's a big boy he was in the military
right he didn't start off as a comic
though right he's an actor that turn
time he was in that Kevin Hart movie a
couple of movies in that he's more of an
urban comic deal for being a white guy
yeah his crowds more urban I took on
Breakfast Club and yeah yeah he was in
the Marines or something he's been a
shitload of movies are using right along
huh I remember I never met him
Undercover Brother doesn't think like a
man yeah you've been a ton of stuff I
didn't think his background was stand-up
that could be wrong it might be a new
thing I don't know either way he's not
bad he's pretty funny I've never seen
Stannis good actor I think he had a
special though I think right yeah I
don't like talking I shot I don't mean
that he's a problem when I say that I've
heard like [ __ ] Tony this Gary served
in the US Navy you're right there I've
joined after a year of doing stand-up Oh
misnamed funniest servicemen in America
you can't do in stand-up in San Diego
developed a large african-american
fanbase you wanted to win funniest black
comedian San Diego he's just staying
that's hilarious that led to his first
gig at The Comedy Store in Hollywood in
1997 he didn't know for a while that
means that's really wrong you notice for
BET's comicview to appearance in on the
Comedy Showcase one of them is one our
grandstand show at the end of the season
he was selected for the all right was
dubbed black America's favorite white
comic yeah yeah I know he's huge in that
Simula I thought he got a special on
Showtime or something like that DVD he
was on he's one of the headliners of
Martin Lawrence presents 1st amendment
standup I'm sure I'm sure we'd like him
I'm sure I have money
but I have mine let's get him on
somebody shout out somebody tells me his
face is difficult to work with now I
didn't mean that I don't want said
that's kind of rumors I don't [ __ ]
know I don't even I don't know either
pissed I even brought it up I don't know
the [ __ ] context in fact he's a spoon
or wiped out something sometimes they
tell me this this guy's hard to
difficult to work with and then a friend
of mine I'm like I know that guy
he probably flew in on a red-eye you
want to do press at 4:00 a.m. I mean
like he probably wasn't he probably
wasn't the most outgoing so you think
he's an ass that's why I don't like I'm
saying something about him that that
he's not we don't know and also yeah
your context I don't like that yeah
you're a bad guy but we should get him
on reach out to that [ __ ] my mom well
okay how that [ __ ] yeah I said all
right what other can I want to talk to
him so dr. Dre posted up a photo of him
and his daughter with her acceptance to
USC and the caption was something along
the lines of she got in all on her own
no jail time for me and he quickly took
it down because people started
commenting what about the 70 million
dollars that you donated that much money
Oh billion by dre that's right [ __ ] I
think Apple bottom right four million
are you kidding me how about these
throwing shade on all the people you
encounter at USC and then I don't know
why in the world I do that and people
went excuse me sir your daughter got in
after you made a 70 million dollar bonus
and that he named a building app I mean
think about things before he deleted it
and this is some old people [ __ ] after
you delete a tweet they think people I'm
like oh I didn't worry time around I see
it soon as you post them like that
people just snapshot it let me see his
daughter or just a picture of a secured
I'd like to see her profile go to our
Instagram truly young
now watch your tone now dr. Dre we don't
want him on our case now no way down
I'm not saying [ __ ] he's very attractive
young lady she can beat these nuts in
her mouth oh Jesus I'm gonna ask you she
looks like uh no she's got a seesaw it's
legal baby well she just got in so still
legal right she might be seventeen all
right ma'am Oh
enjoy your career stalling what happened
what happened to Brandon well although
she's 19 yep cool
oh wow she put 19th birthday oh yes I'm
Claire Elliot
yeah yeah yeah dude you're gonna have to
take it back Wow yeah what a beautiful
woman very pretty yeah her dad's so rich
yeah her dad's pretty awesome single
taken [ __ ] off that's funny
pops pops her dad's pretty gangster yeah
yes well she's a skinny little thing huh
yeah there's pretty nuts let's see
Prince let's see what let's see that
video on Prince let's see what he's
saying there alpha there's any audience
that I can't be played great video girl
great I mean epic [ __ ] how great was her
prize here's a channel what else you got
so a Texas man brings his steer to Petco
to see if they truly did uphold the rule
whole animals are welcome as long as
they're on a leash you look how big that
[ __ ] video so we kill him well that's
weight-wise I'm sorry haha I am dude
look at the horns on two apples look at
those horns is he like an award-winning
bull
I don't think so how do you do with that
he [ __ ] oh yeah that's a Texas long
that's a long horn bro oh come horns
look at the horns on that bad
[ __ ] and look he knows how to
navigate his horn stupid or watch you
like tilt his head
holy the part I'm sure the guys twerking
on his neck but yeah that's impressive
watch because I yeah duh that's amazing
what a cutie pie what do you do with
that thing
what a cutie dude how awesome see him
just wrecked I was gonna say off
suddenly just season starts calling
Thank You goood
he's cute yeah he's super cute until he
decides therefore he can the dude those
are Zee biggest horns oh that's a crazy
should I've ever seen in my life life
so would you just have them breed with
other animals until you make Bank mr.
Haggans died I don't I'm not a steer
former I don't I don't know but a stud
right damn those are the thickest horns
I've ever seen it's a craziest [ __ ] they
were cool with him being in there mm-hmm
no way they welcomed him in and I guess
he just kind of hung out for a bit
damn that man is just super happy I know
he's a dog training zone I don't look at
the manager they do taking the picture
with him Wow what what what what but
what are you saying I'm just saying look
how happy the man is dating Vic you know
I guess now we're saying it cuz you have
a judgment I'm sorry what
it's an angle everybody has angles that
they're not as flattering as other angle
I don't really tell him up well I think
you're being a jerk Oh what else we get
and why is that guy wait go back first
light is that why just the Bulls he's
gonna in the back who's holding his rest
and I was invited cutie pie exactly like
a nice shucks I'm cute you want to get
out of the picture oh right well he
looks like he's got it he's catching a
chill all right moving on so a Russian
man tried to smuggle a two-year-old
orangutan out of Bali he bought it for I
believe three thousand dollars from
somebody he himself had like lizards and
geckos in his suitcase yeah he sells her
he deals in and why do that be sick to
have a baby orangutan ivory i
rehabilitated them in in the wild
they've told us three many of times all
right well just sayin but they were so
cool right they're like children would
they grow up and they can get you know
small right it says you can be okay
there's such gentle so yeah they're not
like chimps let's do one for the studio
there's such amazing animals and by the
way you would get you'd get us attached
that little guy as you would a human
Holland they look like children they're
just
like them I'm telling you they throw
tantrums do they have to be in diapers
yeah and they're so cute and they get
really a lease now I gonna test you they
protect you from people so if somebody
grabs you you know they'll grab you and
push you away and stop do they rip faces
off too or no no they do not do life Wow
there was one story of am a guy who came
across a female orangutan it was take
who was sleeping on the ground and he
scared her so much that she reached up
grabbed his hair and poultice some of
his scalp off and ran away but that was
it dude they're super cool looking yeah
they're really cool I mean you don't
want to go grabbing [ __ ] with a giant
male but they leave you alone they're so
cute they're so cute do they have
eyelashes I want when I spent two weeks
with you got a little good little fat
guts and all hairy and I don't know if I
told you this but the adolescence will
take the children up in tree and rape
them oh geez they do okay why you gotta
go darker I know and we're having a good
time so I'm gonna ring my friend guys by
the exception the guy the guy was there
who was taking care of the orphans they
were orphans and ones variability you
get really attached them to like your
children and when he saw he came running
by me with a wrist rocket advertised
right a wrist rocket oh you know this is
a wrist watch it like you're designed
and and the adolescent male had pulled
one of the little females up there and
was trying to [ __ ] and you can hear her
making noises
so he was [ __ ] her whoa yep and so
this guy was taking his [ __ ]
slingshot and hitting that thing just
going boom and hitting it and of course
he let go of the dam and he came running
down all jumped in hole jumped in his
army jumped in his arms and then the
baby held on to his leg or exam and he
just kept [ __ ] he was so angry had to
stop him you trying to kill that
arranged he was trying to hurt it he was
going and you could hear him whine up
there right he crying he was like good
news and hitting it it was great it was
the big one oh no big one was getting
hit and going hey Garrett and he
wouldn't let him down from the tree it's
all yeah it was so angry mates man yes
dude I saw another one an adolescent
rape a chicken
weird story but he was [ __ ] a chicken
grabbed hold the chicken [ __ ] its
mouth and it was [ __ ] no just trying to
[ __ ] it and it was so weird and we were
watching and it was it was opening it
and then me and my sister we watched it
it was the craziest and by the wings and
just like this yeah and just line mates
though and you couldn't take the chicken
out so the poor chicken was all [ __ ]
up it's a joke you know you know [ __ ] it
well yeah it's a chicken though you know
but they masturbate they perform oral
sex on each other well they say to
others dick
they're just like have you ever seen the
champ that [ __ ] the Frog yes that's the
concept like he keeps opening its mouth
and finally of them just starts [ __ ]
its mouth they're animals they brought
diam it's a franchise they will do stuff
like that it's it's weird they the
chimps are awful cuz chimps are all
they'll kill the somebody else child
yeah it's terrible because they're
jealous let's not go too dark for the
primates man yeah well I didn't want to
buy a ring tank I find out they rape
everything it's you know what order on
go time means we've talked about this or
on gluten orange notes orange orange
something orange jungle around Bhutan
means person of launch of the jungle
forest orange person of the forest
yeah person good job dude you want to
see a skier orangutan the one in the
jungle book movie the things [ __ ]
scare ad is huge who did the voice of
that oh the staff or Christopher Walken
it's an amazing that's actually an
amazing movie I think
I can't wait for Aladdin in liking yeah
I love this movie I thought it was not a
great movie incredible what else we got
this year Rob Gronkowski
how cool is that no [ __ ] he's retiring
is that because of injury or he's just
oh I just think I think guys are
becoming so much smarter now he goes
home on I have this much money in the
bank
injuries are popping up I'd be an MVP if
one super balls I'm 29 I've probably
fifty million dollars in the bank when
we gonna sit around just get [ __ ]
brain trauma
I have Hollywood offers say a bunch of
other business is going on [ __ ] this man
Wow guys are getting smarter and smarter
and smarter
dude I had a conversation with Rose
Gracey because I made the comment I'm
below the belt that hopes you don't mind
me saying this I mean
below the belt that there hasn't been
really any extensive Studies on MMA how
dangerous is for you and I think in like
10 15 years we're gonna see the same
movement the NFL has where how bad is
for you because I know the week guys
train how they get concussed like that
I'm telling me man people go MMA say for
the boxing MMA sit NFL's worsened MMA
Mountain and so she trained she was
biting people sent me what you said and
she goes I want to send you this sent me
a study it's actually the most dangerous
sport I bet it's actually Y V Moser to
kicking and punching each other in the
head during practice and that which
they're trying to figure out which they
can't even get statistic on that how'd
you get actually bite / / competition /
concussion / Kappa MMA is way higher not
to mention after there's a knockout you
know guys get get few more in again
that's one of the biggest problem what
happens Stephen Thompson was horrible he
was out and he got hit two more times
Michael Bisping Dan Henderson sir
there's some horrible ones har but she
set me on this date I get so I got a
dive into but I start just but I think
in 10 to 15 years
once the vets are getting older and we
see it a little bit now Chuck and you
know Coleman and these other guys but as
he gave to I'm telling it's gonna be
nasty man I'm gonna be nasty
I believe it I'm sure it will be it's
just life I was gonna wish they had a
doubt and even even like jujitsu you get
concussed sometimes you know not as bad
it'll be a [ __ ] though you know
wrestling wrestling takedowns yeah but
i'm telling with MMA I'm telling you I'm
saying I'm saying MMA is wrestling
jujitsu tall all that but with the
practice on even in the ink competition
when you were gonna be bad now they jack
locked up and fell I got concussed and
fell on your head yeah my net and your
neck was [ __ ] up for three months and
still is sir still is I still have neck
problems the injury I have yeah I
remember it I was like you did I just
watched you fall on your head and I went
oh my how kind of fight same thing a
fight because it's gonna show beer he'll
take Travis Browne down I'll and the
double leg he lands on my neck yeah
young cast me that almost knocked me out
and then my neck cream injured again oh
Jesus Christ
but I I do I think in 10-15 years
they're gonna have the similar issues
that the NFL has where they're gonna sue
[ __ ] out of them you see guys with real
problems man your favorite fighters
gonna be drooling [ __ ] their pants
not knowing where they're at they could
make it they could I don't know how you
do it but when you see a guy get knocked
out the additional punches it's hard to
stop I know the rap jumps on him right
away but then I they try to but then
yeah I don't know what you can do if you
enjoy combat sports of Union if you
enjoy football partly get you sign up
for a man I need to tell you I agree I'm
not saying that wheat they should change
anything I'm not saying that all what
I'm saying is the fighter should be
compensated because years from now
they're not gonna be able to support
themselves yeah that's my thing that's
right that's you know you know what the
fighters could do they could take a page
out of the comic store the CFC back in
the day back in the 70s when the comics
did to the Comedy Store with Mitzi shore
how they all got together in the
headliners who were getting paid you
know when tight we're gonna we're gonna
pick it we're not no one's gonna perform
do we get a certain percentage of the
door if the fighters would if they would
just read that book if they would you
just you know that's how this worked
with them cuz you had guys you had guys
like [ __ ] the big boys the biggest of
the big Andy Kaufman Robin Williams for
all of them go alright these lower
comics should begin paid we're balling
but we're not gonna perform anymore
unless you paint everybody yeah and it
made a change the fighters they you
don't need a union to do that now they
all from the tops of the bomb go we're
not doing anything till we get a
percentage and what a great time to do
it with this ESPN deal going on what
does that explain that everything so
everything fight night's fight cards
paper views is on ESPN Plus now you
can't watch it anywhere else
paper users will be on the UFC kind of
deal with with us everything's on ESPN
now so we don't know the figures how
much you spend pay for all those rights
we have no idea but if you're the
fighter you're not getting people points
anymore and it limits the outreach that
you're gonna get the exposure you get so
now it's a finite amount of people
master is basically a CSP at the correct
but it's a USP em but also do UFC us
usually do also have won one place to
put pressure which is the SPN
we have exactly so now you they go okay
so it's just on here
the fighters went we don't know how much
you guys paid do UFC do this but we're
not fighting unless we get a percentage
of what you paid them from top to bother
and now and now what how great would be
if Connor goes I'm not fighting to pay
these guys cuz he has more money than
God be great so he doesn't need to fight
you know be great if everyone did it's
the right I could ramble on all day
right thing to ever gonna happen but if
they just took a page of the comics for
it CFC the CFC if they took a page the
[ __ ] in the 70s what the big Richard
Pryor got involved evil Johnny Carson
gyres fair Johnny Carson the biggest of
the big slam were with you guys they're
taking advantage of you and Mitzi shore
bless her heart said the same thing that
Dana says but we give you a platform
yeah but there but without them you have
nothing
you're just a building you're just a
cage you're just an arena without the
talent you're nothing's right and they
should be compensated that I don't
present a hundred percent
don't get me started what else we get
doing nice try as I've ranted for a
third also it'd be really nice to per
fight you have a certain amount of money
goes into a pension for you like a
long-term pension would be nice I don't
know the numbers though I don't know how
realistic all that is anyway all right
this is all over the news and social
media oh my god did you see this I can't
watch it make me to matter they caught
this [ __ ] Lisa caught the gun [ __ ]
who are building problem yeah yeah they
caught it he's [ __ ] I mean how
do they not do I want to jump on that
guy choke him the [ __ ] out oh so there's
more updates that came in not that it's
mentally disturbed what's weird is it's
the other person they're claiming was
mentally disturbed
so the old lady was according to his
fiancee and his daughter
I guess she they the woman the old lady
was saying I'm gonna kill your daughter
and your wife from an established not
does she have a knife I'm sure she was
just saying Randy his wife yeah then
finally he snapped a photo shoot yeah
and then he started kicking her in the
face that's the story that I read up to
definitely kick her crazy all day in the
face she's old lady you don't see yeah
well she however if she had a knife
sweating my kid I'd have to kick a [ __ ]
in the face I don't think she had an eye
for an eye
so this is the pre yeah this before look
at all the guys just video he's not he's
not I thought it's gonna be kicking way
harder and he's showing off any show
well you can't do that dude you can't if
you said I don't care what she said okay
also the pussy's on worldstar filming
this what are you doing miss its Christ
he can't do any she's just her heads not
all they're definitely not there he
wasn't with his family he wasn't with
his oh he was his kid walked out behind
him yeah police say inside of the 36
year old Mark Gomez expect to be charged
with second-degree assault third-degree
assault harassment connection on the
subway attack mean here's the updated
thing where there's got major problems
and he worked at a restaurant like a
very high yeah as a dishwasher here's
the problem though also when he went
yeah worldstar I mean just it's like
okay now you're now you're bragging
about it but you're not gonna get it so
Mark Gomez fiance Alicia Cox Cox said
that 78 year old victim repeatly
minister and her daughter as they were
headed home from birthday party on the
northbound to train March 10th I'll stab
you you and your wife and your child
she kept growling she kept going off
about stabbing killing people just get
off the next exit and move along her
hand
oh did she did her daughter got got up
to get off and she alleged shot I'll
kill you I'll kill your wife I'll kill
your daughter
again she'll I'll kill your daughter she
said something and she had something in
her hand she was I'm shifted towards us
in the door god that's tough man you're
leaving that's tough she goes towards
you anything she has a knife there well
there's children as the story but yeah
like she was doing anything but sitting
that I have to say she looked like she
was a crazy lady mumbling to herself
agree and I think that when that's the
case you can't kill agree if she's
coming at you and you have a daughter
and she has a knife you gotta kill her
but you know or whatever you have to do
to keep but but that didn't look that
way I don't I believe that he's I
believe that probably she was saying
that you know how I know he's a dick
is when he look like yeah worldstar that
liked to brag in on like oh dude I might
have been so angry at that point but if
I'm angry I'm not turn around to the
filmers going yeah that's right
worldstar like it's also it's also
insane like you know that's gonna end up
you know wearin yeah it's a terrible
situation well hope we get to listen
he's not the monster they say is he's a
good father [ __ ] head he was defending
my daughter he calls her my daughter or
my stepdaughter he calls her princess
sir sir you can't do that you can't do
that can't do that Brian you talked
about this loss I'd love to kick in the
face like that though so this is that
girl that you're talking about yeah so
she's humongous on social media she was
like a million some subscribers and her
everything she preaches is all about
veganism
she has meal plans yeah for sure and
then she was caught eating chickens also
type of religion then it's a religion
it's a religion as well but but also is
paleo keto it's a form of religion maybe
as a form of did that's right it's the
most emotional issue in the world
Koreans especially Rogen will tell you
but you also everybody makes fun of
vegans that he never gets more hate from
anybody more than V correct
my mom's a vegan Saul roaster too but
the thing is is with with what's
instrument food is like it's in right
eat sugar you if there's a synapse right
dude right it's it's incredible yeah
also yeah my god it was she wasn't she
was doing that raw vegan diet and she
was missing her period and she wasn't
healthy she was saying oh let me see her
even or not she looks like she needs
some cucumber sir same eat flute now I'm
what you have to say now let me see it's
a long video how same pretty much what
Brian saying why 33 minutes she was
having a lot of issues she looks
unhealthy there 30 minutes of explaining
basically I can't do it anyway I hear it
though they still rely [ __ ] you you know
the vegans are a lot of vegans to that's
really didn't do it's a religion they're
definite dude it's like last night I
keep harping American iodine it's around
the game paper that's her no that's her
friend that was filming and this is how
she got caught you'll see her later
she's in fish right there because you're
kind of like leaning over why would her
friend film this I think she was doing a
random video I talked to her friend I
know she's [ __ ] having vegetable
[ __ ] naturally she's crying dude
she's fine you do I'm telling you I know
you want to help and I appreciate I have
the odds I have this vegetable melody
I'd like to yeah I just want to send her
the day I get it dude and I want to help
and I do I have this egg Glen she has
got to see she's a fake vegan I love it
raw wanna Ravana well you know well I
read about this I I forgive you raw
wanna because you're doing what's good
for your body and it's not you're eating
the percentage
you're not eating just raw vegetables
and by the way plants feel pain too so
what about that do you take a bite out
mo mike says i'ma [ __ ] you up man that's
a plant and I [ __ ] nurture those
things like in my own fish you piss on
my dare you eat fish I love people who
are like this alright and then there's
this Ariana Grande
you've got song that's super famous
right now seven rings she signed away
90% of the royalties just to use that
song hold up signed to a ninety percent
of seventy songwriting royalties to
rodgers and hammerstein you know the
these are a few of my favorite things
they're the ones that composed that oh
she's using that so she's ninety percent
but it makes sense she's already super
freakin rich in Bob pop-ups we can
actually move up
Hammerstein's work genius system dude
aeration is a little slice of heaven
definitely especially boy and
she'sshe bastard [ __ ] on Big Sean just
came out that he suffering from
depression gosh it's almost like I want
it now yeah the cool thing to do a
little depression well just a Mia says I
suffer from nos insomnia and depression
never suffered from either one of my
life but I love it but I'm trouble sleep
one but yeah oh Wikipedia now has Brian
Brian dance well the dance caddy did
that you did Julia private I don't I
don't know how to do Wikipedia Brian
full of dance Callen hilarious [ __ ]
um you want another one yeah one more
man this isn't a great time for us but
it's it is on the news about Frank
Shamrock did you hear about him tying a
dog to a truck pickup truck for five
days but he tried everything possible
not to to protect the dog he tried to
call everyone to pick up the dog this
and that he got it from his mom who had
surgery recently she couldn't take care
of dogs anymore yeah so he's trying to
find it if a home or shelter and he had
to fly out so he was trying to go to all
these different places no one would take
it in the shelter's ruined two unit
shelters went taken he said even called
airport security saying there's a dog
that's gonna be tied to the truck can
you please pick it up no but someone saw
the dog there for like multiple days
it's just a dojo boom and I had talked
with him very nice guy great guy great
Lee really good guy he was crying in
this interview too he said he tried
everything he could he had no like he
was just desperate yeah like this yeah
yeah what do you do what kind of dog was
it I don't know it's an older dog that's
about six and a half year old dog I
forget a picture of it it's a chocolate
lab hmm he any call that much people
trying to get it and then dog was there
for five days yeah they think four or
five days dog died no it's a lot it's
it's being taken care of by the SPCA so
it's all good well yeah I would assume
that if you're desperate you taught the
dog you know the ASP is gonna come and
get it so he shouldn't be it's not like
it look he Zelda is the name of the dog
less-than-ideal
cool name all right what else we got
right what do you what do you got Brian
you know I got that fellas very moving
um so there's a there's a guy who was
this if this is a review about your
special I'm gonna but no no sounds very
moving the best thing he's ever seen
very well
complicated ape sizing yeah thank you
for Miami I'm excited but anyway but
thank you for reminding me if I should
maybe promote a little you've been
polite now so a Texas scientist named
James P Allison just won the Nobel Prize
in medicine because in 1993 he found out
that you can use the immune system to
fight cancer and he was in 93 injected
these rats with an antibody from you
know and the tumors were gone and now
it's a huge part of cancer therapy not
for pancreatic or glioblastoma but for a
lot of cancers and it's saving lives
especially melanoma melanoma is to kill
you in an in a month I mean in a year
within a year a melanoma now a lot of
people live in it with a metastatic
metastatic melanoma the stuff that
spreads to your brain and your lungs
people are living not only are they
living 10 years but but some they think
some of its curative and I found this
moving because he's like 78 and he his
mom his brother and his two uncles died
from cancer and his mom he remembers
holding his mother's hand when he was a
kid
she had burns on her neck because she
she got radiation from lymphoma and as a
kid he was he just didn't understand why
she died and it never it created such a
void for this guy and then he went to
medical school and decided to start
working on cures for cancer and when he
came up with this cure the most
important thing is everybody from all
over said you're foolish this is
ridiculous you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing and it all did was made him
more angry more determined and now it is
saving countless lives and bristol-myers
Squibb 'he's I think was the one who
bought it so that's another example of
where big farmers not all wrong they are
saving lives so [ __ ] off everybody I
mean you know but either way it was a
really cool story cool man but but but
but it goes say man if you think that
you you have a die
that sucks just keep at it just keep
doing it because it does suck eventually
find out if it just keep shooting mice
up with antibiotics and and making those
tumors go right Brandon that's what I'm
trying to say
well now you bring this channel
screeching halt oh dude how about that
thing I shot seven years ago for Comedy
Central here's this Friday oh yeah I
mean central that's not happening 11:00
Pacific you're a lot younger but you
know listen look a lot younger it here's
this Friday on Comedy Central 11 o'clock
Pacific time and it's seven minutes long
how they made that 20 minute bit and
descent myth have no idea so I have no
idea what to expect you know trailers on
their site right now on YouTube but the
full version comes out June 11th on
their YouTube the whole 15 minute bit
but the main one is you should know it's
official May 17th my actual 1-hour
Showtime special airs on Showtime sounds
good buddy come see me in Philly this
weekend I'm sorry tickets are all gone
but there are still tickets left for the
Late Show Thursday Calgary April four
five and six Yuk Yuk's let's go get your
tickets Denver obviously April 25 26 27
Comedy Works downtown near Miami and May
I'm telling you dude oh I can't that's
Club in the country I'm a knight best
club in the country I believe it man is
my favorite city in some ways yeah I
don't say that you're me I don't say oh
just excuse me
Thursday Friday Saturday man watching DC
Saturday shows are sold out there are 10
tickets left for Friday's both shows 10
tickets toll and Thursday let's move
some tickets Thursday Friday Saturday
this week
t fat k dot-com for tickets and then
just on sale Phoenix I'm at stand-up
live next month Phoenix after that I'm
San Antonio get your tickets now chief
at kake.com and this Friday this is not
happening Comedy Central 11:00 Pacific
tune in y'all love you guys but wait a
minute I just found that Calgary sold
out already so we might have another
show sorry did you add another show not
yet but I'm going to so it doesn't
matter does anybody do can you read
another story for us and put us to sleep
that was a little long this is the vibe
kid